a neurologist is testing the effect of a
drug on response time by injecting a
hundred rats with a unit with a unit
dose of the drug subjecting each to
neurological stimulus and recording its
response time
the neurologist knows that the mean
response time for rats not injected with
the drug is 1.2 seconds
the mean of the hundred injected rats
response times is 1.0 five seconds with
the sample standard deviation of 0.5
seconds do you think that the drug has
an effect on response time so to do this
we're going to set up two hypotheses
this is we're going to say 1 the first
hypothesis is we're going to call it the
null hypothesis and that is that the
drug has no effect on response time and
your null hypothesis is always going to
be you can view it as a status quo you
assume that whatever you're researching
has no effect so drug has no effect drug
has no effect or another way to think
about it is that the mean of the rats
taking the drug should be the mean mean
with the drug with let me write it this
way with the mean is still going to be
is still going to be 1.2 seconds even
with the drug even with the drug so
that's essentially saying it has no
effect because we know that if you don't
give the drug the mean response time is
1.2 seconds now when you want it's an
alternative hypothesis the hypothesis is
no I think the drug actually does do
something so the alternative hypothesis
the alter the alternative hypothesis
right over here is that the drug the
drug has has an effect or another way to
think about it is that the mean the mean
does not equal 1.2 seconds when the drug
drug is given so how do we think about
this how do we know whether we should
except whether we should accept the
alternative hypothesis or whether we
should just default to the null
hypothesis because the data isn't
convincing and the way we're going to do
it in this video and this is really the
way it's done in pretty much all of
science and you say okay let's assume
that the null hypothesis is true if the
null hypothesis was true what was the
what is the probability that we would
have gotten these results with the
sample and if that probability is really
really small then the null hypothesis
probably isn't true we could probably
reject the null hypothesis and we'll say
well we kind of believe in the
alternative hypothesis so let's think
about that let's assume let's assume
let's assume that the null hypothesis is
true and so if we if we assume the null
hypothesis true let's try to figure out
the probability that we would have
actually gotten this result that we
would have forgot you gotten a a sample
mean of 1.0 five seconds with a standard
deviation of 0.5 seconds so I want to I
want to see if we assume the null
hypothesis is true I want to figure out
I want to figure out the probability and
actually what we're going to do is not
just figure out the probability of this
the probability of getting something
like this or even more extreme than this
so how likely of an event is that and to
think about that let's just think about
the sampling distribution if we assume
if we assume the null hypothesis so the
sampling distribution is like this it'll
be a normally it'll be a normal
distribution we have a good number of
samples we have a hundred samples here
so this is the sampling distribution it
will have a mean and now if we assume
the null hypothesis that the drug has no
effect the mean of our sampling
distribution the mean of our sampling
distribution will be the same thing as
the mean of the population distribution
which would be equal to 1.2 seconds now
what is the standard deviation of our
sampling distribution the standard
deviation of our sampling distribution
should be equal to the standard
deviation of the population distribution
divided by the square root of our sample
size so divided by the square root of a
we do not know what the standard
deviation of the entire population is so
what we're going to do is estimate it
with our sample standard deviation and
that's a reasonable thing to do
especially because we have a nice sample
size a sample size greater than 100 so
this is going to be a pretty good
approximator this is going to be a
pretty good approximator for this over
here so we could say that this is going
to be approximately equal to our sample
standard deviation divided by the square
root of 100 which is going to be equal
to our sample standard deviation is 0.5
point 0.5 seconds and we want to divide
that by square root of 100 is 10 so 0.5
divided by 10 is 0.05 0.05 so our sample
the standard deviation of our sampling
distribution is going to be I will put a
little hat over it to show that we have
approximated it with we approximated the
population standard deviation with the
sample standard deviation so it is going
to be equal to 0.5 divided by 10 so 0.05
and so what is the probability so let's
think about this this way what is the
probability of getting one point zero
five seconds or another way to think
about it is how many standard deviations
away from this mean is 1.05 seconds and
what is the probability of getting a
result at least that many standard
deviations away from the mean so let's
figure out how many standard deviations
away from the mean that is and
essentially we're just figuring out a
z-score a z-score for this for this
result right over there so let me pick a
nice color I haven't used orange yet so
our z-score you can even view it as a Z
statistic it's being derived from it's
being derived from these other sample
statistics so our z sam our z statistic
how far are we away from the mean well
the mean is 1.2 the mean is 1.2 and we
are at 1.05 so I'll put that less just
so that'll be a positive distance so
that's how far away we are and if we
want it in terms of standard deviations
we want to divide it by our best
estimate of the sampling distributions
devious sample sample standard we want
to divide it by our best estimate of the
sampling distributions standard
deviation which is this 0.05 so this is
0.05 and what is this going to be equal
to z this result right here 1.05 seconds
one point two divided by one point two
minus one point O five is 0.15 so this
is 0.15 in the numerator divided by 0.05
in the denominator and so this is going
to be three so this result right here is
three standard deviations away from the
mean so let me draw this this is the
mean if I did one standard deviation two
standard deviations three standard
deviations that's in the positive
direction actually let me draw it a
little bit a little bit different than
that this wasn't a nicely drawn bell
curve but I'll do one standard deviation
two standard deviations and then three
standard deviations on in the positive
direction and then we have one standard
deviation two standard deviations and
three standard deviations in the
negative direction so this result right
here one point oh five seconds that we
got for our 100 rat sample is right over
here three standard deviations below the
mean now what is the probability of
getting a result this extreme by chance
and when I talk about this extreme it
could be either a result less than this
or a result or result that extreme in
the positive direction more than three
standard deviations so I'm this is
essentially if we think about the
probability of getting a result more
extreme than this result right over here
we're thinking about this area under the
bell curve both in the negative
direction or in the positive direction
what is the probability of that but we
know from the empirical rule that
ninety-nine point seven percent of the
probability is within three standard
deviations so this thing right here you
could look it up on a Z table as well
but three standard deviations is a nice
clean is a nice clean number that
doesn't hurt to remember so we know that
this area right here I'm doing in this
reddish orange that area right over
there is nine
nine 99.7% so what is left for these two
magenta or pink areas well if these are
99.7% then both of these combined are
going to be 0.3% so both of these
combined are 0.0 0.3 I should write it
this way exactly our 0.3% 0.3% 0.3% or
if we wrote it as a decimal if we were
to decimal would be point zero zero
three of the total area under the curve
so to answer our question if we if we
assume that the drug has no effect the
probability of getting a sample this
extreme were actually more extreme than
this is only 0.3% 0.3% one in less than
one and 300 so if the null hypothesis
was true there's only one in 300 chance
that we would have gotten a result this
extreme or more so at least from my
point of view this result seems to favor
the alternative hypothesis I'm going to
reject I am going to reject I am going
to reject the null the null hypothesis I
don't know 100% sure but if the null
hypothesis was true there's only one in
300 chance of getting this so I'm going
to go with the alternative hypothesis
and just to give you a little bit of a
little bit of some of the name or the
the labels you might see in some
statistics or some in some research
papers this value the probability of
getting this the probability of getting
a result more extreme than this given
the null hypothesis given the null
hypothesis is called a p-value so the
p-value here
the p-value just really just stands for
probability value the p-value right over
here is point zero zero three so there's
a very very small probability that we
could have gotten this result if the
null hypothesis was true so we will
reject it and in general most people
have some type of a threshold here if
you have a p-value less than 5% which
means less than 1 in 20 shot they'll say
you know what I'm going to reject the
null hypothesis there's only less than
there's less than a 1 in 20 chance of
getting that result here we got much
less than 1 in 20 so this is a very
strong indicator that the null
hypothesis is incorrect and the drug
definitely has some effect